meanwhile Judicial Watch is suing the
Justice Department for communications
between Bruce or Nellie or Christopher
Steele and fusion GPS joining me now
with more is Judicial Watch president
tom Fitton
gopac chairman david Avella and fox news
contributor former Clinton pollster Doug
shown ok you know we've got this link
between steal or and the Russia oligarch
but there seems that there's no way for
Congress to get information in their
oversight attempts there's no way the
Justice Department is giving information
via Freedom of Information the only way
we're getting information now is as
usual through tom Fitton and Judicial
Watch all right so now Tom you get all
this information about the oligarch and
Christopher still what what is that
about
well look Christopher steel it looks
like was working with fusion gps even
back then which we have to remember was
representing Putin interest in court in
here in the United States trying to
target Putin's critics and the key Putin
critic that led to the Majin ski act
that was famously discussed at the Trump
Tower meeting so he had these Putin
interests pushing obviously it looks
like the Justice Department trying to
push it on the Trump campaign this
approach to removing the badge in ski
act that was curtailing their of the
rights of oligarchs in Russia in terms
of a sanctions regime and in positions
and sanctions so the irony here is that
fusion GPS was working for the Clinton
camp to target Trump also working for
the Putin camp to target the government
generally in terms of get in this [ __ ]
ski but then it suggests David that the
Russians would be colluding with
Christopher steel to make Trump look bad
the Democrats right now judge are
pushing the biggest blame shift
or blame-the-victim strategy that we
have ever seen in political history most
Americans don't know who steal or this
Russian oligarch are yet a convincing
number of them now realize there were
people working for Hillary Clinton who
would say or do anything to keep Donald
Trump from being president and it only
underscores why Hillary Clinton had the
lowest approval rating of any candidate
in presidential history you know
Judicial Watch Doug we find out found
out after Steele had been fired by the
FBI the Bruce or met with him to launder
information to get back to the FBI but
it gets even better
or was trying to get a steal back to the
FBI as an informant or a human
confidential source whatever they call
him but more importantly he was trying
to get him on the Muller team this cabal
they're all incestuous you know I guess
my position is somebody in the middle
here is all of these documents that Tom
Fenton and Judicial Watch are seeking it
strikes me in the interests of Justice
not partisanship would it be released so
we know what the facts are that'll help
us judge every aspect of this
increasingly murky case you know let me
just ask you this because what Doug says
is so true no one has questioned any of
the information you've unearthed you
know no one is saying it's not true it's
not this it's not that but every day we
have to fight for everything
to what end are you getting this
information obviously you get the
information out we know that the public
square but what do you want ultimately
Tom you're working your butt off here
well we think the corruption scandal of
our time is this targeting of Trump
using the FBI and DOJ in league with the
Clinton camp and Russia interests to spy
on him and try to destroy now his
presidency and I frankly think Congress
is walking around or trying to talk
around Muller's involvement in all this
Steele was part of the Moller operation
remember which initial watch uncovered
the FISA warrant application signed by
Rod Rosenstein in June of 2006 17 last
year yep right in the middle of the
Muller operation Muller was using
Rosenstein excuse me Steel's information
source number one the fusion gps dossier
that Steele helped create to justify
spying on Carter page of the Trump team
or you know who had been formerly with
the Trump team Muller has a lot of
questions to answer about his
relationship with Steele his use of that
material because I'm convinced Muller
was pursuing the Clinton DNC dossier all
through his investigation and it's all
based on corruption and this is why
Muller needs to be confronted directly I
would like to see Congress bring him in
and ask him questions about his use and
misuse of leases oh okay
does Congress have the authority to
bring him in of course they do
it's a fear-based decision-making in
Congress they are protecting Muller at
the leadership level and he needs to be
held to account the way every other
government bureaucrat must like the way
you think tom Fitton
David what's your response to that
Democrats thought they were going to
bring havoc to Republicans this year in
the elections by pushing this shifting
the blame blaming the victim strategy
and the reality is it's is one thing
that is motivating base Republican
voters to go to the polls to make sure
that Republicans get a fair chance in
this election Doug you're the pollster
what's gonna you're the Democratic
pollster what's gonna happen I think at
this point the Democrats have a clear
advantage and the reason is it's not so
much that this investigation of these
issues we've been talking about are
impacting voters I don't think they are
it's that there has been a sideshow for
the Republicans that's taken emphasis
off the economy off the tax cuts and all
of the benefits and if I could offer my
Republican friends some free advice talk
about the economy talk about the proper
the progress in 1982 the Republicans
slogan under Ronald Reagan was stay the
course the Republicans need something
like
otherwise the Democrats will take the
house which is where things stand there
you know when David Avella you are the
the head of go pack I mean you have your
your tentacles all across the country in
terms of state legislators what do you
think of what Doug just said the idea of
stepping on our own good news story by
going after this Russia collusion does
he have a point he does have a point we
do need to be talking about the economy
but let's also keep in mind and the
Democrats keep talking about oh we're
gonna pick up you know if we win
seventeen State Legislative seats we
pick up eight legislative chambers
across the country judge if Republicans
pick up eleven seats we pick up six more
chambers and we already have 67 of 99
we'd have 72 of 99 this battlefield is
every bit as competitive for Republicans
as it is for the Democrats and the key
will be which base turns out to vote
well I and I think Doug was really
talking about his you have the historic
the precedent advantage Tom where are
you going next
oh we're fighting the FBI over text
messages for the corrupt FBI official
Andrew McCabe the FBI doesn't want to
turn over one text message to us they
mine this blows my mind the president of
points
Christopher Rae the first time he
testified before Congress christopher
ray does the dance well you know we'll
hand you this stuff over so now we have
to not just ask for a for you we have to
we have to sue in a lawsuit all right I
think I had the last word